مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في قناه الجزيره
وقع رؤساء الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي وحلف
الناتو في بروكسيل اعلان المشتركا للتعاون
والتنسيق الامني ردا على مسموه اخطر تهديد
للامن منذ عقود وعقب التوقيع على الاتفاق
قالت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
ستحصل على ما تحتاجه من مساعدات العسكريه
قال الامين العام للنيتو ان روسيا تريد
تهديد وحده امن اوروبا وان هذا الذي يحدث
خاصه الاعلان الصين بالتحديديه مبادئ
الشريكين في مواجهه عالم نيورادو تغييره
في المقابل قال سكرتيره سال امن الروسي
نيكولاي يا بتروشيه من الغربه يريد محور
روسيا من خريطه العالم وان الحرب في
اوكرانيا تت مواجهه معناتو
اعلنت السلطاته المواليه لروسيا سيطات
الكامله على وسط مدينه سوليدار
الاستراتيجيه في مقاطعه دونيزكان الشرقيه
بدات عمليه تنشيط المدينه من جانبها قالت
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان القوات
بلادها ما تزالوا تدافعوا عن مواقعها في
دار مؤكده هذا ان الجيش الروسي يواصلوا
القتال رغم الخسائر الضخمه التي منيبها
قال الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير رزنسكي ان
الوضع في دونياسك صعب ويتطلب مستوى جديد
من المساعدات العسكريه وقد وصلت وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه انا لينا بيربوك الى
مدينه خارجي الاوكرانيه في زياره غير
معناه زارت خلالها خطوط القتال الاماميه
في المدينه ووصفت الوزير المدينه برمز
الجنود المطلق للحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
اكد وزير الدفاع الروسيه سيرجيو ان روسيا
ستواصل تطوير ما وصفه بالثلوث النووي
وستحافظ على جاهزيته القتاليه كيضع منديل
سياده وسلامه اراضيها وشدد شيريغو في
اجتماع بوزاره الدفاع على ان روسيا تخطط
ايضا لتوسيع الترسانه اسلحتها الهجوميه
الحديثه في المستقبل القريب
اعتبر العياشي الهماميه منسق هيئه الدفاع
عن القضاه المعزولين في تونس ان احالته
للتحقيق على خلفيه تصريح اعلامي تندرج في
اطاره سياسه رئيس البلاد وحكومته في
التعاطي مع المختلفين معه في الراي اضافه
لمحاوله تغطيه على ملف القضاه المعزولين
على حد تعبئه وقد اتهم نقيب الصحفيين
التونسيين محمد المهدي لجلاصي السلطات
بتحويل البلاد تدريجيا الى سجن كبير للراي
على حد تعبيره
في اثناء دعم رئيس وتونسيه للاستعداد
الكامل لتنظيم الدوره الثانيه الانتخابات
البرلمانيه
[موسيقى]
شكرا لكم